this is our real thoughts again Rob
doesn't know what we're doing Rob since
we talked about Nicolas Cage last time
let's talk about the Ghost Rider movies
both of them because there's really no
point in separating them we can really
talk about both of them in one video I
feel hate
okay now here before we even start this
is one question I know everyone's going
to want to know the answer to
uh which one did you dislike more the
first one or the second one because it's
a surprisingly tough choice like they're
very different but also very similar in
their stupidity
they both have some cool scenes they
both have Nicolas Cage not trying
you've been trying at other random
moments a horror of is I'm trying to
separate the two in my head to be it's
almost as one Jamin the second one the
second one Ghost Rider looked better
like he looked like a literally cool
skull it was burnt and the fire looks
like it was you know flaming off and
stuff without first one handle in the
second one the second one was the boy
with the the devil wants to take this
boy and consume his body Oh
Antichrist or whatever then ah that
could have been just any shitty like
late 90s movie with the devil in it from
that literally like I feel like that is
late 90s I think I was early to that I
know it's early 2000s but that's what
pisses like no that's what pissed me off
about it more is it felt like something
that was so antiquated literally by the
time it came out like everything had
that kind of like I would say like end
of days and all that shit like it I feel
like there was a stretch from like the
late 90s to the early 2000s where is all
those fucking Devils coming back movie
that's that was really it again yeah
just boy that one stupid movie I I will
say this there was probably in some ways
some better action in the second week a
little bit more of Cage freaking out it
got more of Cage freaking out but I
hated the story even more at least the
first one as shitty as it is is an orgy
and I
what that story was shitty yeah it's
really hard to do when you really
believe you're busted sorry dude she's
21 is the worst one cuz everyone's
always like oh the first one far worse
all the second was far worse like
there's no everybody's behind just
compromise and say we hate them both
yeah I don't know like I don't like
either of them um I liked I never read
ghostwriter religiously it's the world's
most amazing image yeah like that's
because it is pretty oh you know the
problem is when you're a kid we weren't
exactly rich so I had to kind of pick
and choose which comics we could get cuz
you know we would only get a certain
allowance or our mom would only be like
not even only buy one so Ghost Rider was
all those always ones that I really kind
of wanted to read but you know catching
up and hearing so I lived vicariously
through Ghost Rider through like you
know other kind of collections or the
Marvel comic cards never when he would
show up in other comics so I just cross
over the x-men sometimes yeah yeah he
would show up in some of the x-men
comics we had like so I liked Ghost
Rider and from what I remember of Ghost
Rider this wasn't very good but um what
for what I hear like was this huge Ghost
Rider fan he has like a tattoo of ghost
riding everything and from what I
understand the character he's just
phoning it in it just so looks like he's
not trying hitting it in until he
transforms then he goes pure cash ha ha
ha ha ha ha you know he goes nuts yeah
that's right that's what we think we're
gonna see and we get a little bit more
than the second one but not much yeah
it's it's really a pick your poison
thing cuz the the first Ghost Rider Cage
is less crazy it at least is an origin
story not a good one um and I feel like
maybe was a little bit more of a
coherent narrative but the second one I
thought the story was even shittier kind
of like just crappy hand-me-downs from
like other bad like late 90s early 2000s
films and but the action was a little
better in Cage was a little crazier yeah
but I didn't like the villain really and
I'll say this like if I wasn't I
couldn't tell you I honestly I think you
know what it's like Lord of the Rings
instead of thinking of it
has three individual movies let's think
of it as one giant movie and in this
case one giant pile of shit you know and
with the first film I like if I was a
producer and I read the script to that
film I'd be like okay these are rewrite
but this can work I can totally see you
know there's good ideas with him writing
down the building him like throwing the
chain around the helicopter and bringing
it down you know fight that part was
actually really cool yeah well your
numbers Ghost Rider it's it's not that
bad just the fact the skull looks so
silly
that's the the effects couldn't the
effects couldn't keep up but the idea
like that scene in particularly sticks
evidence with a few scenes I remember
and I'm like that was fucking bad yeah
and him writing down the building was
yeah so but everything else around it
just kind of you would it then had the
dead hid the taint of David Goyer on it
didn't it ever if he was the first one
the second one but I think he produced
the second one I don't know about the
first one did he write the first one at
all
I don't know and that one I'm really not
sure yeah like it up I need to know is
he because he hates David going like
Morton no but because there's something
that really stuck out and that was I
felt the first one was just a carbon
copy of blade like I watching it I'm
like yeah the villains the way like the
villain yes that's another villain
psyche damn Elliott is basically
Whistler I felt like yeah that's good I
felt like it just was showing from the
comic though and I you know when I saw
the trailer for the first Ghost Rider I
really wanted to like it I in looked
kind of cool and Nicolas Cage seemed
like you know good choice and everything
and then we're watching it just seems
her seemed like a Saturday morning
cartoon almost with the way they acted
and the way the lines were she brings a
magic 8-ball to her date you know like
just to serve this joke of like will he
show up oh no and it's like why what how
um and I can't feel bad for that actress
cuz I feel like she could be a
legitimately kind of funny comedic
performer but she had to be
quote-unquote serious and this even
though they throw in dumb scenes like
that but whatever she had
see way she has to just kind of funny
expression like when she's interviewing
him there's a great scene where you know
he kind of doesn't answer this question
she brings the mic back them back to him
the back to her that that was good
comedy I thought that legitimately kind
of worked okay so no he did not write
the first one he was executive producer
okay so his taint was there somewhere
but that you know he he produces like an
exec an executive producer can make a
number of calls he could have just said
hey give me blade cuz that worked and I
was involved in that he did however both
executive produce and write the sequel
okay and we know how good that was what
I love in the second one there's the
seed where it's like this rule and birds
in it with you know graffiti all over
his face he count looks like it once
again iron when Jim Carrey Russell L
blue on his face is like that as is the
case of everything he's in he's the best
fucking thing in the movie I wish there
was just more of Christopher Lambert but
I love those giving cage like together
would have been amazing food but there's
a scene where he's like you know they're
taking the boy to the devil or whatever
cages like dog oh I have my where trip
on see now won't bring back your fucking
honey is stupid he says simply says
something like I like you know this is
the wrong future doing labor it's like
no and it does to speak close to be it's
like it's not a like oh why did you go
in from a big cause close up on that
line that's a tragedy of them it's not
it's not mortal kombat oh yeah I love
Christopher Lee honestly he was the best
thing in mortal combat she enter a
tournament Mortal Kombat you didn't like
the Johnny Cage shenanigans
muah-muah no I like to make guys that
cracked all this really yeah who didn't
is no is all crisper Lambert um I guess
it's hard to talk about seeing how we
don't know the comics that well but it's
like even from like I just want to see a
comic book movie about a guy whose head
becomes a flaming skull these are kind
of dull safe not interesting movies that
welcome to the world of David go here it
no there's everything he touches there's
like a paint-by-numbers holiday app it's
like it's just paint-by-number it's like
the script always feels hair
complete it just gives you some plot
points you're never that invest in the
characters sometimes it makes no fucking
sense you know it did I will say this
the one thing that I'm grateful for is
that I think this was Marvel sign that
you'd like this guy no we're not Wells
gonna have to close it back no I don't
think so after ghostwriter - I think
that you know why so you can know of
yeah DC can have him and the god fucking
DC's loss I pity oh maybe this was a
Marvel plot how do you we put your name
on it yeah yeah how do you how do you
take it this is looks like that German
plot where I think they shipped Lenin
back to Russia the Russian Revolution
happens and they pull out of World War
one it's like it it's like how do we
take DC down
oh just ship him go yer easy he tanks
the Ghost Rider franchise what do you
think he can do the Batman Superman oh
but uh yeah I'm trying to think anybody
mentions the Dark Knight trilogy
third-string writer and what I said he
area at the same thing yeah same thing
and I'm like in whatever contributions I
think he made - those were the
contributions we didn't like I'm pretty
convinced um yeah trying to think what I
didn't even know what - okay so the
victor so not interests there's a weird
sort of so my wife and I were watching
this show on USA called political
animals chance Sigourney Weaver in it
and it was actually I thought for first
season it was actually really good show
I cancelled after season one but she was
basically playing Hillary Clinton and it
was kind of a fun sort of alternate
universe was a Hillary Clinton s
character who is overtaken by a young
upstart who's supposed to be Barack
Obama except they pushed out and made
him white instead I'm like ah oh yeah
you should have just made it like real
life then we have messed up white hair
like Sanders on and that nothing that's
bad this would have been like four years
ago maybe um I was a while ago before we
all had to feel the Bern um but the guy
they got to play Clinton their version
of Clinton was the same guy who played
the villain a ghostwriter to
and he just had this slimy southern
accent and we just keep saying oh sugar
bumps
oh honey bunch oh it was so weird
because I so loved his performance but
it was not Bill Clinton Elvis's like no
Bill Clinton
no matter what you think of him his
charisma no he liked that yeah that's
his that's his fucking secret I I mean
even Republicans would have to admit
it's like not on that asshole smooth
yeah so this guy exactly could get away
with such a used car salesman playing
this the slimy Clinton Kerrigan oh and
I'm just like good but at the same time
it was so funny to watch that it was
amazing so he bring that to the devil in
yeah that's what killed me up like
ghostwriter to him like I saw this guy
political animals and he was amazing
and then this he's so boring I was like
just once say sugar buns just once just
once it's me sugar Willis yeah you know
the thing to at least with the first
film
neither film represents what seems like
a really good authentic hell or very
credible hell no divide nor did a spawn
from a man know but with the first one
least there's a sense that like the
devil kind of stays out and like he he
sir comes in makes his deals and they
can't goes away then years later he
needs the ghostwriter again cuz is
whatever son Andy Christ whatever is
going on a rampage so he kind of stays
out of he you know he's the guy in the
corner just waiting yes you kind of
imagined the devil is um where with the
second one he's running around he's just
a guy in a black Sunna cars and rock go
faster rah and it's like that's just not
fun to think of the devil that way well
and this was a problem with all those
films at the time I felt like their
interpretations of hell and the devil
were just boring their cartoons like not
even entertaining cartoons yeah and I
don't like if you want to have the devil
in it like I wish they would have given
him like a personality like something
really like even if it's not like good
at least it could be like Eddie Redmayne
over-the-top Jupiter ascending sort of
like okay at least that was entertaining
it was fucking nuts you know or
something to match Nicholas Cage and
Christopher Lane
why even the Cascadia wasn't matching
Nicholas K yeah hey I don't know and
that is so so you didn't feel the first
one was a lot like blade cuz I know when
you mention those like elephants I'm
telling you as you're watching it was
like I just feel like I'm watching a
lame ripoff of blade know like the eggs
like will live the villains in it
reminded me of Stephen Dorff and his
idiot brood no no no the villains I
mostly just and like the Whistler guy I
I could have like Sam Elliott my okay I
might be that this is like you know I
suppose playing film I never got like
there's an underworld or like you know
he's go with the sword or anything or
he's like even the characters don't
really know because Manimal arranged
that character but I felt the way the
story unfolded I felt even the way it
was shot that there's a romance in which
there isn't an blade technically um you
know but like though okay yeah okay
there is animal okay hop hi Jason we
tell you practically but I feel like
even a ghostwriter if the romance was
kind of still shelved much like so it's
just like they won't want extra step but
I just by following even the way which
that just the whole thing exude it's
something blade about it said I got more
like goofy hijinks that which sometimes
have this badass character don't get me
wrong that's there but I'm saying a
goofy bad version of bleh like they fly
Saturday more cartoon of lame I feel
like blade was a template that Marvel in
this case may have been trying to follow
and then they they brought David Goyer
on board and so they've gotta do the
darker we guess yeah we got like more
the same I mean that was certainly a
time where it's like hey if we're gonna
try and make comic book films a thing we
gotta make them dark and gritty but like
even then more just visually not usually
the storytelling the play got you know
pretty gory and everything but after
that I was like not a pg-13 s keep it
pg-13 turns out of monitor turns out
Marvel back then kind of sucked at it
yeah it's like DC sucks at it
yeah um no Marvel was not always the
OCAD no it really didn't start like okay
now you're really fuckin good until this
meteoric rise it has been so impressive
that we forget how fucking rock bottom
fantastic Isle of shit like well and
it's nothing
are okay okay well it's not even marbles
okay it's not even on marble small
because they didn't have direct control
of all of it but the Marvel properties
were not always executed well um and of
course we have the verb like honestly if
you told me right after Dark Knight
Rises or even right after Dark Knight
that this would have kind of switched I
want to believe you out
oh no like DC's got this in the bag I
think I mean look at what they just did
this is amazing like heaven Dark Knight
came out around the same time as like
Iron Man did today I enjoyed Iron Man
but to me to me this still felt like uh
know by me like a long shot yeah but
that to me you're right we don't shy
yeah like if you can cuz when they when
they first said like oh yeah then we're
gonna do Iron Man then we got plans oh
we got plans I got so many films I'm
like yeah yeah we we've heard that a lot
see what happens
sure and then Iron Man was good and I'm
like alright Iron Man was good like I I
thought Iron Man was a pretty good movie
um but I'm like I didn't think at the
time that Iron Man was anything as good
as like The Dark Knight or something and
and then slowly we just reversed our job
they never recovered after no left
yeah Ally even when Nolan was there you
could argue that you know they were okay
I'm sorry Dark Knight Rises has a lot of
problems and it's not great it still was
a command it still was a complete
trilogy ah I'm know what don't like
don't like it but I mean that that's me
I have no no I'm not I'm not a huge fan
of it either but I think you're like too
harsh on it really fucking hate it but
I'll still take it over handing it to
Schumacher and doing Batman Forever and
Batman I'm like at least we got a
finished product so um but yeah that's
our thought on the guys uh and we will
be back next time with another real
thought Nina